okay it's my belief okay so we're gonna
inflate this balloon clean it now when
you inflate something usually if you've
got like constant pressure like if
you've got a pump as opposed to know
your lungs
what will I know about how this thing's
inflating okay walks for instance let's
actually put some numbers on this okay I
have to say a spherical balloon because
balloons are not really in real life
they're not spiritual but unfortunately
because that's very cool we can't bottle
them mathematically very easily so I'm
just gonna make a sphere so that we can
okay so a spherical Buddha balloon is
being fitted at a rate lock the web okay
oh let's see eight meters eight cubic
centimeters of air per sec
so my question is if that's how much air
I put in what's happening to the radius
yeah
how fast is the radius increasing now
before I finish the sentence right I
hope you get that again this is a great
question how fast the radius will not be
increasing at a constant rate okay
when will it be increasing focused at
the beginning right yeah because it's
gonna have you know a radius of whatever
zero okay and then as soon as you put in
a bit of air goes roof right and then
has you that's the exact same place
right as you keep on putting more air
air in at a constant rate okay you've
got to put increasing amounts of air to
keep the radius going and growing and
growing and going right so how fast is
the radius increasing and I want to add
a particular point in time okay we're at
a particular position so when the radius
is how fast is reaching this is for
sentiment yeah okay good so there's the
question how you approach it you want to
look at this and as with so much in
maths the first question is a 1 or
translation right so I have a rate up
here I already mentioned as well I'm
going to have a rate over here that's
the question right so what information
do I have and what am I trying to get
what do I have what am I trying to get
well I've got this right here now what's
it a rate between right before we said
you know you've got D on something and
something else two things that are
changing what are the things that are
changing here for me over time right now
and you can tell that it's going to be
volume over time it's really really easy
you just look at the units yeah so in
the first unit is a unit of bomb it
should accept me though okay and the
second unit is a unit of time okay
so that's why I've got TV on duty right
now it's just equal hey as a as a as a
minor issue right when we're looking at
derivatives same here with integrals
when you're looking at these it's a bit
like pretty Murrells today a unit-less
okay so dig in does he on dt is not a
sin ministry per second okay it's just
eight and then we deal with units later
on okay no that's that's the first
sentence what is the question what are
we actually after we're after the rate
of the radius increases okay so this is
what we know it so what unknown is
radius increases that's dr again over
time and we want to add a specific
position when the radius is four okay
he's my set up right I've got to get
from here all the way over to here so
how do I go about that
following dr/dt and I've got DV DT you
can see the missing component right is
that I've got ours here okay and you
remember for chain rule right I'm gonna
want D on our ADT being equal to
something times something yes
now C is there's a DI here and the DT
here there's gotta be a dr over
something and there will be a something
over DT okay because these things should
be the ones that cancel out that's what
makes chamber what right so because the
only other variable I've got is volume I
assume DV goes here and here okay so
they'll cancel and give me
one so you look at this versus what
we've got
so dv/dt tick I've got that so now I
need to work out this part so dia give
me what that tells you is there's some
relationship between being and arm as V
changes are changes so what's the
equation what's the relationship between
V and volumen Rainey's because it's a
spherical balloon right so you see
careful they didn't give you this in the
question but they sort of did write that
the volume that we're interested in is
4/3 PI R cubed okay so this is the
relationship between VN r that I can use
to get to here right now immediately
when you look at this is dr r DV so that
means you'd expect R equals something
but I've got V or something so I'll
differentiate it the other way round I'm
gonna find DVD on dr okay and because
it's just a fraction I just take the
reciprocal once I've got this okay so
what is the
which is the surface area of a circle if
you remember that the significance of
that result from integration okay
CSD beyond er but what I really want is
the R and D V which is just the
reciprocal so now I've got the DL DT
that I had from the question I've got
this dr or a DV and i can put these two
together into here into my chain rule
okay so let's say div is one on four PI
R squared and this is just a number just
a constant it's always eight a plus so
you can see I've got some canceling so
this would ensue on PI R squared and
that's as far as I can simplify right
okay if they asked for just the general
rate of change what at a specific point
I'd be finished but we want to add a out
of place when the radius is four so I'd
say when R is for the actual rate that
I'm interested in years to over 16 pi
which is one on in time okay so like I
said this is a derivative so it's unit
this okay so to be nice and neat
I mean you could get away with the
problem whacking the units on there but
a better way to say it is the radius is
increasing
but you bring your Radian and you look
at whatever units were supplied to you
so we were talking in terms of
centimeters a radius is just a length
some flats centimeters squared into the
area or send me is huge we volume and
the time unit was four seconds okay
now usually right the difference between
this line and this line is quite trivial
you're just adding some words and some
units to Pat it out a little bit okay
however it's gonna be quite important
later on which is why I think it's worth
putting your concluding sentence number
one sometimes your conclusion will be
about something getting smaller rather
than getting bigger okay so when you've
got negatives here that'll make a
difference for the conclusion and
secondly quite frequently they'll ask
you to do something quite different with
the units okay for example going from
kilometers per hour to meters per second
that's a really common one okay